OMR podcast with Robert Geiss, what can
I say, all of the most successful episodes of
all time, let's go,
welcome to the OMR podcast from a
spectacular location, we're sitting here
just outside of Monaco
on Robert Geiss' terrace, I'm uh
trying the invitation and I'm extremely
excited and  curious about the that the
conversation will come again Robert yes
tomorrow here over the roofs of Monaco
not over the roofs of Nice over
Monaco absolutely
exactly and meanwhile for 28 years
for 28 years 28 years we moved
to Monaco 28 years ago and not
regretted love the coast love the
weather you can see again today the
weather hasn't let us down
it's running it's still working
summer and that in the middle of
August who said you soon with a
motorbike but still a very
unusual route for someone who in
Cologne behaves in a completely normal way,
equip a fair, so somehow have a fair,
um
[music]
yes yes yes fairground rides and no
fairground rides no we have the we
supplied the trade that
means the boys who have raffles at the fair
have shooting galleries etc
that's what my grandfather or then my
father wholesales all these
clothes to  People sells that
means everything from plush toys
to roses to clay tubes that shoots at the
shooting gallery that is exactly
what the company sold wholesale at the time
and you couldn’t
take over that as a successor, but you could have
taken over that but my father
was  relatively young that means he had
me when he was 20 my mother was
18 then you can imagine that
generational problem was of course because the
father didn’t want to give it up we wanted
to earn the money but me and
my brother and then we
decided without further ado we have to  do something of
your own otherwise it takes
too long with the Porsche
okay and you still have studies  t or
or still somehow no no
we gave up studying too
it would have taken way
too long with the Porsche again the
Porsche has to start relatively early
and who knows everyone knows
if you study then you’ll be there
at some point  finished at 24 25 and earns
the first money when you are 627 I
actually wanted to be almost finished at 6 27
didn't quite
make it but at 30 I would have finished my
studies but come on so when did
you start to become an entrepreneur or yes we
did  then basically we did my
apprenticeship with my father in the
company to get a taste and
see how the whole thing works, of
course got to know
the trade and trade on a level that was really,
let's say, a bit
tangible but  You can imagine that the fair
is similar
to the market again, so that's really
a good level of action, that is, at a good level where you can  can learn a lot
and the teachers of course helped me
a lot thereafter I had
the idea of ​​making textiles then opened
the first boutique
but found that it works the
music I often made for my
now wife my girlfriend who came
with me at the time
I've been in a relationship for 40 years now and
we then built it up together,
then I brought
my brother along and founded the company onkelzem together with my brother
and politics
was in Cologne, but it
was on Ehrenstraße at the time, that
was basically the test balloon over  you can
see this kind of clothes
it was jogging pants uh
t-shirts leather jackets but then 20 or
so then I was 20 years old somehow
said okay I'm in the mood for clothes that
should work somehow I'll buy one
somewhere and then I'll make one
Pharmacy on I buy somewhere
else the the the the the clothes
found in Spain  en on
vacation and imported them to
Germany and then found out
that they sold very well in the pharmacy
that was something new, people
walked around in jogging suits back then
they could
see the people at the gas station every weekend everyone
had jogging pants  on is almost
Bock somewhere now back then,
every bouncer back then of course he
confessed with the J prognosis with the
leather jacket sometime after five years
then with mine with my brand that
means we then tried to make one out of
what we had done in the
boutique  To create a wholesale
small boutique I have an 80
square meter boutique in Cologne and that's
when the idea came up that what
we do in the pharmacy should be done in
wholesale and practically say to all
fitness studios in
business language, so to speak, the
value chain is extended as a
criticism now to the goods
procures itself, so to speak, exactly that one in the
Pri  nzip extended the economic chain
and that you start producing the goods yourself
, creating your own design
and then selling the whole thing to the
masses at that time it was
n’t that easy because
there was no internet yet, there wasn’t
all this media and it  there was no
social media, etc. there was no mobile phone
, so you had to see how
you marketed it and there was the one
who was the big giant back then,
Neckermann, etc., with large
catalogs that people got from the
start and we had exactly the same thing
we basically followed
two concepts, the first was
the catalogue, the classic mail order business
and the metro the metro was
classic wholesale at the time, that means you
had a shopping card with the
shopping card you could shop in wholesale
and we put it all in
the  Catalog brought we had a
price list in that catalog
in that Uncle Sam catalog over there  nn in
the time spirit has grown from four
pages in the end we were I think at
360 pages so basically invented the one
I myself we didn't invent the catalog
we adopted for ourselves we
saw exactly Neckermann auto mail order
that's what women do  love where
people look in pictures beautiful pictures
beautiful women the whole thing is then
taken over with beautiful women and
bodybuilders etc. and then they sent these
catalogs with a circulation
of 1.2 million circulation
6 months in mass mail that
means you could back then  already
buying addresses like you
can buy it today more complicated than today
but you could buy addresses from
fitness studios addresses from
beauty salons to dentists etc.
where we sent our catalogs in mass
flour every six months 1.2
million catalogs you can
imagine  that's two or three trucks
full of catalogs that we spread across
Germany  including
all the marketing measures that you
could do back then you could only
advertise in magazines etc. that
went from the bottom up
to the praline I would have said soon
there was still
advertising around all these
customers like that  to create but such a
business actually
needs financing you have to
pre-produce the goods you have to pre-finance this
whole catalog printing and everything else
or you have that was
the second problem that means
we naturally had the first three years in the first two
years
Initial difficulties of the whole
financing and then we had to look for
partners and thank God I
found a German-Turk who was
well connected in Turkey and
together with him I then founded the first company
in Istanbul so on
partnership and he could rely on
me  could rely on
him and so of course we could
spread relatively widely from one company and at that time it was common
practice in Turkey
to buy fabrics on a monthly basis two months
payment term three months
payment term you simply
paid a bit more then
practically got the credit from the fabric
supplier to produce the products
and  Since my Turkish partner
could trust me blindly at the time, he took the
risk in Turkey, I took
the risk in Germany and
so we basically achieved a double
effect and were able to
finance all our stories, but
we only had a
few boutiques  at the beginning
we expanded the whole thing to three four
boutiques but then
realized relatively quickly that they are so
cost-intensive and so labour-
intensive the profit from the staff
is
too small mail order itself
was much more
interesting and much more lucrative in the 80s than
all about boutiques or  he
stationary trade and how big was the
business then at the end at the end of the
day we did what did we do we
did then in the time when I
sold then we went from 0
to 120 million in sales at that time of
course Dema no euros but that  was of
course a real bang within 9 years
within 10 years
so that was totally profitable that
was profitable yes we had about
25% return over the whole thing because of
course the stationary trade was
excluded we
actually have almost no boutiques in the boutiques
we didn't sell anything, we went directly to
the end consumer and
so the marche was of course completely
different than when you sell wholesale these days or you
still
design or do the right marketing
yourself. in the beginning I designed everything myself because of course
we didn't have any money for
designers  etc. over the years we have of course
also set up a design office
where designers made the suggestions
we have of
course expanded
in Turkey we sometimes had 5000 people in Turkey
the real produces 1000 people is yes
you can smell 5000 people someone
Turkish partner had to handle thank
God thank God I didn’t have
much to do we  were set up in Germany
with around 120 130 people
we had a company in France with
25 people we had a company in Holland
I think 15 people
worked there we were
set up across Europe and in
the end if you’re honest
we would have continued with the whole thing  haunted if we hadn't
burned out you have to
imagine you did it for 10
years from 20 to 30 my brother from 19
to 29 to 28 and we were
really a bit exhausted with our strength
and then we had the offer just
that  first offer at that time via the
Kaufhof who wanted to buy us there was
already the connection to Otto Versand
etc. and then we did the whole thing a  n can
senders sell for a lot of money and yes it
is public and then we left in the end
so 40 million in any
case get so much too much money
that it works for the time being yes that you can
party on the Cote d'Azur for the next five years
so the
number that is circulating could be that we are 40
million euros
yes I can't calculate that in euros at all
that was more than 100 million
Deutschmarks at the time and for us the
sum was 100 million that was about so
you have in each
If you are in a good position for the pension, that should
work first, okay,
yes, I celebrated my 13th birthday here in
Monaco after I
bought my condominium here, for
me, of course, you know Cologne, for me,
Cologne was the moment I was
selling  Cologne done for me, I
immediately put my house up for sale and
it was clear to me that I would like to go
south. At that time I
thought about going to Mallorca
I didn't like lorca as an island
because that was just always had to take
the plane and you can
never say I'll get in
the car in the evening, drive 67 hours or eight
hours and I'm from the Cote d'Azur
to Munich, you always have to
So taking a flight to Mallorca was
not an issue for me in the end and
it was clear to me that the Cote d'Azur is a
great coast. Back then I always
went to San Tropez for holidays. I liked
the flair. I liked the
lifestyle  the people were all
chic everything had spirit and Monaco
yes speaks for itself everyone knows mine
and everyone can read
about it Monaco is glamo Monaco because my brother
once brought such an article
to the Stern after we sold it because he said
yes it would go to Monaco  I don't go
because the Monaco I ca
n't feel rich at all and he's right
about the Monaco is actually everyone is
enough that means here is just one
of many and that find  e I good that
means nobody here suffers you
anything if you someone Bentley that
's almost as if you
drive a VW in Germany
okay that means what was decided that
too you don't have to stay like that so
the sale was that for you  the last
working day that yes it was almost the last
working day i naturally had a
five-year consultancy contract which
thank goodness was very
flexible i.e. my advice was then
limited to creating the collection
to giving the input which
clothes are in which for the next year
Colors, what designs, etc.
so basically I only had to work two or
three times a year for a week with
the whole story and I came
back from a skiing holiday
when we were still skiing in the Arlberg
I came back on January 3rd or 4th
and then they said  new owner
yes i could clear my office now
because the next
collection viewing of the sms and i
could come back in March and
then I came home briefly on the third
afternoon Carmen
stood opened the door what are
you doing here I have my
little body here I have emptied my office
there are a few others coming
Put the suitcase down, I'll put my
basement down and we're free now, so without further ado we got in
the car the next day down
to Monaco, we
already had the apartment at the start because the
sale had
taken place in November, in December I was like that
quickly and have four Monaco already
bought an apartment down here
and went looking for a
single-family house of course we need
something on
the Cote d'Azur for the apartment in Monaco so that we can
really feel I don't want to say
enough  but let's say
seeing the reward for what you
've worked for and then we quickly listened to the
songs about 40 minutes by M  bought onaco and
house and for me the
most important thing was that the house
had a swimming pool but I really wanted a
tennis court because the tennis court was
what I had for me so much success
hey you did it because you only have
a swimming pool but you have  ok
ok your father was then still working
with the with the with the with the fair to say
produce products yes
logically very disappointed that
his two successors went flying
that they were gone all of a sudden
that my brother then went to
Mallorca in the end me  I then hung out here on
the Cote d'Azur and he
had, thank God, I have another
sister who he then hired, who then
had to serve and
then continued
to do wholesale business with her until at some point he
realized that it doesn't work without a
successor  and i have another
cousin
and then he sold the whole store to my
uncle and my cousin for the
store  continue today and tell me how things
went for you then you went
on vacation here first of all i totally recovered
and then at some point started
throwing away real estate logically
had to recover from the stress first then of
course first find yourself
you had to manage your money you
had to manage your money  I then had to
learn myself
to become independent again because at that
moment you obviously have
120,130 people in Germany or 5,000
people in Turkey everywhere for
something, that is,
if you needed or need new tires on the car
it was winter tires
or a car had to be registered
or you wanted a new mobile phone or
you know someone who is
responsible either has a chauffeur
you have a secretary or someone
did it for you that
means the moment I then  was
done for me this January, I
first stood in front of where does my hand come from
y from which contract do I
even have how do I even register a
car okay now bring winter tires here
and then I suddenly realized
that a tire change like this takes a whole day
until you found the right tires until you went to the tire service
and changed them in the
afternoon  I had never had
anything to do with it before, my cars
were clean, they had gas, etc.,
so I had to build something up again relatively quickly so that I could get on with it and
then very quickly
overhauled houses, etc. again, a
tribe of 56 people who  there were people around me
who were responsible for
everything, one for the garden,
the other for the cars, the next for
dead, so that everything was up and running again
because that was actually the
most difficult thing at the moment when you
get out of a business like this  and, to
put it in German, you get your ass
kicked around by your employees afterwards
organize but tell me you are so
business savvy
what I can hardly imagine is
that you sold this company without
going through such a process without speaking to
various potential buyers
that says the first one who
approached you was
still the second  it wasn't the first
so this Kaufhof story didn't
work
because they had a scandal with the mail order company Oppermann back
then and the
entire board at Kaufhof was
shaved that's why this deal didn't
work and we're just in
came to the next sender and he
paid even more money and
then we said okay we'll
close the bag here first and then
we'll see what he wants to do want to
actively sell yes we did
n't approach it we had a
management consultant or an agency at the time  who did
something like that professionally, who had
the people up his sleeve and
who  went out and said we
have a lucrative company here
where we had already passed the exams for
everyone we had
already passed all the exams from the Kaufhof
that's forever just that the company was profitable
that they got big votes and and and
that we  just don't
screw it up like for example there is
Germany yes there was just etc. such
a nice example of that so they put
us through our paces and you
knew haha ​​the company is worth what the
company is lucrative the company can be
expanded and so it was relative
simply selling the company
and for us it was
very, very important at the moment because you can
imagine we were but 28 I was
29.5 and then turned 30
to get so much money for us that is at the
moment  first once and then you
say you grab it some don't do it they
say we keep working we
want more and more more and more
for me it was gan  z sure I'll
close the bag here first and
start living my life for now okay that
means you've never regretted
doing it but we'll do it if it's
continued until today it would
probably be worth a lot more
because after that the new one will be  market came
after that this whole social media
story the whole internet started clean
that of course gave the
Ver abused everything an absolute
kick again that could definitely
have grown again that could definitely have
doubled
tripled on the other hand my grandfather did
back then he always said you can only
eat one schnitzel because he's right because
after that it was enough for us until he was full
we wanted to find each other
again afterwards you can
always do something new at 30 I
did something new afterwards
I did  first four years five years
six years did nothing yes for 5
years just enjoyed my life
P  arty bought my
boat when the Mediterranean Sea
drove from Ibiza sondrupe from Mallorca to
Portofino and just let me
go ne Miami and God knows
what all
that you need so that you have little time before
Behavior with a woman yes yes
assuming now he has got so much
money shoot the woman first
because now he is hanging down there with the
handsome and rich and
lots of mice will jump up from the right and left
, of course they
jumped up too, they also danced at the table
but me  I'm faithful with my wife
because every divorce also costs
money
we got to
know each other back then in the clique we got to know each other in the disco
more or less
in the click that you had
in the 80s in Cologne Weiden and  yes,
it turned into a long relationship,
we wouldn't have thought of it at the time either,
so that means you have to have the
party here, such an A  rt enjoyed your 30s
, um, but at some point
we looked at becoming
entrepreneurial again, yes, then certain
external influences came
, of course, we sold the thing
in '95, of course we had golden
years from '95 to 2000, shares
that we knew were made less  I don't even know
why he made textiles at all
before, but you could
earn a lot more with shares and much faster
and without work and without anything until
2000 and the first crash came and you
realized oh it's not all growing
to heaven there's that too
some dark times but do you
really know investors
I was good at it and I
lost a lot of money no question because if
nothing was lost and
I hadn’t invested anything I had invested a lot
so I lost a lot so that was
the first setback I had  who was
also good from today
, of course, had two or three vapors over the last 20
years  r where you saw
hey it doesn't just go up, it
goes in the other direction and
then I started saying you have to do
something sensible again you have
to do something that has substance and
then I came up with the
Cote d'Azur because I like the coast
and there are a lot of
old objects here, old castles, old palaces,
old chatos, etc., and then I started
to buy the first one and rebuild it,
renovate it, restore it and
then sell it to someone who has more money  is
he
okay and that's also for a German
guy and get Martin to buy the locks
there is no problem
it's the whole thing of course that's a similar
problem with permits with
everything just like in Germany I
've started to do the first big
object here  in Monaco with 24
apartments, of course I came directly
to all the Monegasques who of
course have roped parties etc. where you
didn't even have any before  ht starts from where it was then of
course difficult to
get approval because you just need a
certain stamina
to prove yourself in a business like this and
then we made objects that
we bought two locks bought two
statuses which
I then converted  At that time I also took a partner with
me who was also familiar with real estate
that is all
paid for from the cash flow or did you go there
too we did that back then we
logically
had to do it from the cash flow after 2000 so
I then also decided for the for  the other
properties because we suddenly had a
lot you can
imagine 24 apartment in Monaco two
castles in France
so and then the next one up here will
be offered again and and and then
here in Monaco we are also a
community of  from German where there are also
many
who have sold their companies also have money
and from 2000 it was p  more practical almost
impossible to get loans after
the first crash the banks
withdrew again and did
n't finance anything so you had to cover the
whole thing from your own cash flow
and thank God we managed
that pretty well we
have them  Objects ready built we
have these were big big construction
sites so a valves 5 million others
sold for 8 million further
so the idea you
buy for 500 sells much much more
so 8 million would have been a good
profit and that’s how it was  the
biggest order where the whole thing
moved and you did that somehow 10, 20
times then we did that, uh yes
, we often did that back then, okay
years, so from
to the apartment complex, so to speak, but
to the apartment complex I also have
three single-family houses  built i have
in san tropez we
bought several houses partly demolished partly
completely  newly built, partly only
renovated and enlarged the house where we
live now, we
practically only bought a plot of land back then
, there was an old provincial
house on it that will be demolished
, we built new on it, so
all these things were rebuilt from the ground up,
renovated and  it worked wonderfully
and he has to be there it was
fun for us not only for
me but also for Carmen to
set up the whole thing to design the whole thing
to see behind the success and
then to inspire people afterwards to
do things well
find and also to buy and the
added value out there,
so to speak, via an internet platform
or, like back then, the internet
didn’t even exist to the extent that it did back
then via the agencies that were the
top dog via the real estate agencies that existed from tropez
Monaco etc  then customers have
found international customers I
then sold to Russians ver  buys we sold an
Arab we also sold to
Germans so we have
across the board the taste that we brought
into the houses has the
style we lived at the time and that the
houses identified it
worked and the success has us
At the end of the day they were right
and we stopped with that I do
n't even want to say that we
stopped with real estate, we've actually
always done it I've scaled it down a bit,
these these big things
that they said you have to have
two three four construction sites now
I only scaled that down with the number
that we started on TV and in
the end the real estate business was
more lucrative for you than you considered overall or
thanks fighter sold no I would
say the uncle together with the uncle fights the
sale was clearly the basis for
what else you do  then
I could make money out of this so I
guess I will at the end of the day
I made more money with the real estate
than she did with the whole textile business
before and one results from
the other but if I had
n't had the textile business I wouldn't have had
the foundation to do the
real estate and everyone knows
it's natural I don't want to now
just say buy something for ten
convert it and sell it after 20
and has earned five to earn 5 million cash
there you have to
sell some truck
jogging suits for textile patterns
and also produce them accordingly and
then you just said on television
how did you get started  plus with the
TV well I mean you lived here in
Monaco and lived a good life doing
the real estate up and down the coast
and then he's TV
far away for a start TV was
gradual if you're being completely honest
because tv is gradual that's
natural  back then it went through the press
in Germany that we were
selling the company  and that would be
relatively young and then the
glamor status was of course Monaco and
trope that was of course also
given on top of that, so that there were
always one or the other
TV station who wrote to us
or called us Robert will
be able to do something new  we don't even do a home
story we want to see how life was
because now what do you have new house
have there new car have new boat
or what do I know that means they
were always looking for a
story and then we actually
always  once a year maybe
sometimes twice a year I made a little home
story like this 5 minutes here four
minutes there 6 minutes what the heck and
err please magazines that
still exist today doesn't matter if it's exclusive doesn't matter
if it was red back then doesn't matter if that  Formula
exclusive at that time was with Kabel is a
good friend of ours with whom I
also made two or three programs from
which my house then showed my chateau and
w  eat the cuckoo was apparently
always very well received on television
and they had a very good response to
it and good ratings and so of
course one or the other
production company approached us and said hey
didn't even want to do anything bigger and
then there was then  this story is good
for Germany and then we
said good for Germany it
was a long time ago for us but okay if
you want to do an episode like that then
we made an episode I know
fifteen minutes good for Germany from
this first episode there was
lightning fast  I think six or
seven and then at some point we
realized that we didn't like it
because this contrast, especially
in Germany, between the
Reich and someone tried it then
in Iceland, I think it was a
woman who went to Iceland to
breed horses  wanted to open and
worked there in the stables and 5
minutes later Robert drives with d  em
Monaco didn't suit me, it
then leads to envy and the cuckoo knows what
and didn't feel like it and I
said without further ado that mine doesn't
go on anymore that's too much
I don't want this contrast you
like I do mine from time to time  home
story but I'll stop there and
then we stopped doing it and then
it took half a year and
then the next production company
said hey we're going to do it all so cool
with you you did well with
Germany you need your own
format
Then I was told what your own
format looks like and what you can do with
it and what
added value it can have and how
big it will be and and and then
we said okay, let's do
sex episodes, then we'll actually have them
made the first six episodes of their own
production, the Geissens, which are
still running today, we are now at
episode 340, which means that the success proves
us right  that would have
started on a small scale back then and have
continued to expand it and at the beginning it is
somehow let it be produced,
but a company in the external
production always
does the
first 100 episodes themselves, I think we have the first 100 episodes with the
Cologne production company
then we started our own business or
found out that does
n't work, they're not at our level,
we have to think about it ourselves, we have to think about it
ourselves what do we want to do where
do we want to go how should the
show look like you can't
dictate it  and you
always have the problem with production companies
that people
want to decide, they want to bend people, they
want to tell something
about how it has to be done, etc.
and we never did that, so we never let ourselves be bent anywhere, we never told each other anything
we have always stayed
true to our line  We always wanted to be
authentic, we never wanted to have anything scripted
, along the lines of hey, the argument is going
great, you have to
argue with the children, or Carmen,
I have to argue with you,
we don't have that kind of thing here, we show what we
want to show like we do  want it and
we don't let anyone talk us into it, so the
logical consequence was
that we set up our own production company,
that we manage
ourselves, that we produce ourselves, that we
think up the stories ourselves,
that we now of course also take part in everything we do on our
own
in connection with the children they
sit together like a small
family council and then
think about what we're going to do now but mom
want there Dubai they want to buy your apartment
I'm keen even if he doesn't
feel like it we still buy there but
we can get along  then
come visit but we actually
do everything together and overl  Eg then
which travel destinations
can be lined up for which travel destinations there are
certain ideas where you then say okay
this summer we're going by boat to
Ibiza or we're going to Sardinia and
who's up for it and then
the children decide the same way, yes I want to in
August  because they are friends in Ibiza
okay all right then let's plan
August Ibiza like this and in this
holiday we then basically plan
these four five days or this week of
shooting so that the whole thing is
basically a very authentic
number that  So that means yesterday
we were on vacation now we're going to be shooting for four days and then we're going on vacation but
in the same place back then the
Kardashians or something like that sometimes
you compared the German formats
that are somehow relevant to
you already known or looked at
or something  I
didn't know them at all at the time and
logically I came across it or came
across it  Of course
there is also a family in America that does the
same thing as we do and they are very
successful with it.
Of course, America is also much, much larger in America.
The English-speaking area
is of course much larger
looking at the whole thing naturally noticed that there are five
pretty girls who work
there and do a mum who
sits on top of it who knows exactly where to go
it's similar to
where dad sits on top of us and then
knows exactly how  it goes a long way
who agrees with the woman who then
gives the rest and thank God the children
then settled in
over the years and I think
that worked quite well
was it always clear to you
that you were like that  Are you interested in the
public, I mean you've
earned your money, you've been living as a private person
here outside of
Germany  could have had
an anonymous life somewhere
, many prefer that too, but
apparently you don’t, so you
kind of had fun doing home
stories too, so
satisfying this wish too, it was
always in you that that person
me  it's alright i'd love to
have it nope it wasn't in my mind
if i'm honest that means over
the years i was doing uncle
sam i was very very
new to the press if it went anywhere in the direction of
press shelf on any
Events or
at fairs we made FIBO
big back then, we sometimes had a 1000 square meter stand at
this fitness and bodybuilding fair
and when it
came to any
newspaper interviews or
press stories, my brother always put it
forward, I was actually the
one who was always behind  was
the public was shy and that has
in principle actually m  ith the sale of
the company I started living
down here in Monaco that
somewhere I relaxed a bit
I was a bit
absorbed in my business at the time I only had
my business in mind I just wanted to
make money I just wanted to have a
successful life  and
the press was completely uninteresting for me
and it practically only started
with moving down here to Monaco
after sontrap that the whole thing became more
relaxed then, as I said, I did
this first, this first show back
then that was think it was in Kitzbühel
I was called Home
Story, my sister came with
me and said I know someone in
Cologne called
Pankwitz who I think worked for RTL at the time
and he says
Robert can't we do
something for you then you have there now  there is such a
farmhouse in Kitzbühel we would like to
do a Kitzbühel Story that's actually how it
all started  well,
the first episode wasn't that professional at all,
that was also a
lot of stuttering and and because you had
to get used to it first and
found out okay the feedback from people
is actually very, very good, which
means he has his circle of acquaintances too
great show, well done, we think it's great
that you're finally showing
what life looks like and that
's how the whole thing developed and then
you became more and more self-confident
and still found it fun,
that's when I basically
became more and more self-confident and  you
said the whole thing but just
told it came slowly that
is practically this whole
television career built up over 10 years
so practically from 2000 to 2010 and
then in 2010 we started with our
own
program we just have to be in at least
once  Dozen or more broadcasts on
TV where you could say it's working, it
's working  people accept
that they want to see that they also want to
see what's going on in monaco what's going on in san
tropez how do these people live what's
happening there and why shouldn't we
show it to people
because of course it's a
fundamental question to include the children
too because  I mean in
Germany there is a big discussion
now with Instagram should you
show your children or not show that
we made a clear decision
and came together obviously
no that's not a problem for us they
were smaller back then um we'll take them in
with us  we will also be
public, so to speak, that will be a clear
decision, of course we said so at the time
and said
if we do the whole thing without
children and let the children out
then we will always have to spend many days without the
children because we will be
shooting this tv box  if
we do this as a family pull together as a family
we will as  family
now spend many days many hours
together because suddenly it is also
a business and that is why it was
clear to us from the start we do it
in the family we do not live in
Germany we do not have this contact
with the German fans every day
we live in  monaco relatively
withdrawn from this fan hustle and bustle that
exists in germany in san
tropez we are relatively anonymous except for germans or swiss or austrians the french do
n't know us so in that respect we can
move around freely with the children just as they
can go to school in the  School
if you don't recognize them because there
are maybe two German
children running around at school the rest is English the
rest is French the rest is white
the big
ones come from everywhere internationally for us it was clear we want to
do it as a family we want family travel we want as a family  drive around
the world that's what we
did then we have  when the
children were ten or Davina helps
but made the trip around the world over 4
years by boat from here via
Miami Bahamas through the Panama
Canal over to Hong Kong to Taiwan
the children we always had that was
also a problem back then the
You just can't
get children out of school for four years because we would
cut off the children from their entire
network network what they have from
all their friends we
simply extended the children's vacations
and thank God that's
what's happening here at the  International school
in Monaco it is possible that you can take the
children if the holidays are on October 20
then you can take them out 10 days before
and bring them back a week
later and in between
you simply take a teacher with you and
we always took teachers with you
that they  Children learn the material they
actually need relatively little the week before the holidays and
the week after the holidays
at school  It doesn't happen that often
from our own
times, we took the kids out and
so we could of course be on the boat for 4
months or almost five months a
year at
certain points,
yes, of course there were, as I
just told you  You take two days of
vacation, then there are days of shooting, then there
are two more days of vacation, then you
have three days of shooting again, and so on and so
on. Of course,
you have two dogs for the show
every year  easy going 50
episodes if I watch more 50 episodes will be
broadcast how many people are
watching that was the first broadcast so
first broadcast you have up to 2
million use 2 million viewers on
RTL2 meanwhile you are or are
you as a family that is the
face of the broadcaster  you carry the transmitter we
carry the transmitter with you for sure
yes definitely we have been here for 11
years we are now in the 12th year  Hundreds
are still stable have even
been rising again throughout the
corona phase we are now
partly on the double channel
cut we have some programs
that run at over 9% he RTL2
usually runs at 4% something is
successful for
you  no, definitely not in the long run,
as I said, we broadcast more than
40 episodes a year, I think in the
spring it was 48, the 48 ran on average
, I think with well over 7%
7.27.3% on average,
we actually live from  the success if
that would be fun just for
the money alone I wouldn't
do it because it's basically just
a few more places in the account
which then at some point you stop looking to see
if you have 100 million or
150  at that moment it doesn't
matter much anymore because of
how many people probably
google it every day how much money yes that's
normal your life
only changes with certain things  In a certain volume
that means if you have 50 million
or 80 million you live the same
life nothing will happen if tomorrow
you get 500 million on top of that then
your life will change then you buy
a bigger loaf you buy then you buy
a bigger one  your
own private chat because you now have 500
million but the the the
black between 20 and 50 what
happens nothing if you have 20 million in
the bank
the 100 and then you have to see the
next level I experience that again and
again with a lot  Friends who then have
the ambition anyway I'm a millionaire
what can come after a millionaire when you
've got the first 100 million what's
coming then the billion will inevitably
come you'll get there you have to
work a lot I don't want to get there
because I don't want that much at all  work
is enough for me what I have
[laughter]
is the basis so that I can still
live in peace at 70 okay so what does
this gan mean  ze show is more or
less fun for you now Hobby
yes it has become a hobby and
I think we have perfected
it we are successful as I said
we have of
course built a lot on this business of television
we now have a hotel we
we still do real estate
we have the Roberto geissini
story that we do very
successfully
also six years old that means
it's nothing new that's what we
're trying to expand with the children at the end of the day
the children are
the first  I was in Istanbul at the beginning of the year
, that's
coming in the next shows at the beginning of
January, where the children then get
creative themselves and make their own mother
because logically 17 18 19-year-olds
wear different clothes than
50-year-olds and in that respect we have  which
we have now started too, they make
their own designs, they should have a
look, they should have a look  uppern
actually in everything how big is the
biggest
the the fashion brand which is now in the
several million range
and the children should now just
see how big they want to build it up
do they actually want to go back in the
direction that the whole thing
employs a few hundred people
or  Do you want to keep the whole thing within a relatively
manageable online
framework or how big is the whole thing
going to be? Of course we also do a lot
with licenses we have had several
large licenses we have sold at
Netto we have sold at Lidl etc
we are now coming up with our own
Wine out, red wine, rosé, white wine, also
a license, that means we have
different rinds that the children can
smell in now, as I said, they are
now 18 and 19 of age, don’t want to
study, want to do business, have
their own show, have the first
six episodes, made them in the
spring  are mega successful drops
so well over S  Finally
, the Geissens reach
their own format, but also something
similar to Davina Shanaya we love Monaco,
who basically show how they live here in
Monaco, what happens in Monaco in
the future, they will also show
how the career is, what they are
doing now  So smelling the textiles
smelling the
hotel business or smelling the
real estate artists
the artist in the family she
is basically the creative part and has
the first pictures very
lucratively and always together 35000
€.  okay,
a heart for children, i think it was
, and it went well, yes,
and now she's going on with it after the
next pictures, has now made
inquiries from several galleries in
Germany, has to deliver 20 pictures, 20
pictures is of course a bunch, that
means winter  is actually
full and that's why we want the
best possible yes yes now we're going to
open a big studio where she then has the opportunity to develop, of
course, for the show too, logically of
course one thing results in the other that's why
I say yes from this whole
television story is yes  become more
than just television because everything
else is building but RTL2
goddess only in very small parts to the
big rtl group and that actually belongs to
a private entrepreneur in the end
that he's not part
of groups
that are involved I don't know  what
the ownership structure looks like
I think there are three holdings there
are on one side there's  RTL that are
involved then there are some
investment companies that are involved back
then private companies were
also involved I don’t know what the
distribution looks like at the moment, that means
the boss or the owners of RTL2
don’t call regularly anymore and
ask how you’re doing and then do it
we a bit but of
course the league of the
upper RTL2 calls us all the time and
we are still in constant contact and of course they are
happy when we are doing
well I wanted to say yes they
don't have to worry that
you feel like it at some point
but thank God it's not like that yet
we meet twice a year in
person and sit together and
do brainstorming how can the whole
thing continue how much
could produce and it's always
a process that means you can stick to it
imagine such a program is
not produced from one day to the next
, a few trains of thought  or
are there organizational questions about where
do you fly to where does the next trip
go flying to New York for an episode
isn't worth it because
it's economic suicide that
means you have to think about
where the next tour should go
and when  they say if you do an America Tour,
then the America Tour has to run for at least
14 days, the yield from it
must be at least six episodes,
otherwise it’s completely interesting from an economic point of view
a lot that you can't
earn anything anymore and it has to be the
mix at the end of the year that you have enough profit left over from 40
or 50 episodes that you deliver to the station
for the
company to function but when you say
New York is difficult that sounds yes
as if the margin or that you are
thinking about New York or
London is of course much smaller
than if I  tomorrow I fly to Ibiza
with the line or whether I fly to New York
and then with a private jet to
Miami that's the first 50,000 already
gone I've only just opened a
lie exactly so that means
I hear that one episode
delivers about 60 70,000 that  that the budget of the
consequence yes that is roughly the budget
what you have to budget for what you have to plan for
and there are of course
much more costs, especially if
we are traveling in a private jet or you
are traveling with a yacht a
tankful of fuel that costs  and at the
moment it costs even more than we ever
did because the diesel is also here
at 2.10 and if you can pack 50,000 liters
in such a boat and
that's quickly 100,000 that
change when you fill up the tank this
year  you always want to ask that
you've had different yachts for many years now
no yes I started with yachting
or started with voting  before I
sold my company of course I
had my first sport boats around the time of
etc. that was
fun that was the compensation
we had to have we took it from Ibiza to
Mallorca from Mallorca na Ibiza and
let it go so well in the  Time when
we had each other and then
the boats became natural and that's
just the way it is at Boden with increasing
success the boat is getting bigger and
bigger because in every port you will find
a neighbor who has a larger one
alone is berthed in the port in
Monaco  is that why it's worth
it if it's different so now in
the off-season it's actually still
affordable that costs in the evening or
the night the 24 hours cost 400 euros
if you do it all in the high season then you'll quickly lose 1200 euros
for one  Hello yes that means your
yacht costs per year so if I now
hear mooring uh fuel what do you
have then alone
that's a very simple one  he invoice they
always say the purchase price 10% of
which is what the bread costs and
what is that supposed to be a purchase price
of his yachts always between 10 and
20 million then he can
calculate what the maintenance costs
millions a year yes under certain circumstances
but that has  then RTL2 no of course
I use my credit card
that comes from the budget of
all the companies what comes together in
my drops from that the whole thing is
paid for okay because logically
we also use the yacht privately we also
use the yacht for holidays
etc so that  will definitely not be
completely covered by television it's
just a part of the business
we have and there are many like
I said I'm still on the stock market I have to
invest my money
what do you have we're talking here
somehow  in October 2022 everyone asks themselves
where can I even invest
yes that is the question I sometimes invest
well sometimes badly  Lecht then a
few things like badly laid out
again like that yes I also said, for example
, you have to go sustainable so
let’s buy Bavaria with it because we
will also eat meat we
now want all plastic food that
just didn’t work I
even have 120  bought now over 13 that
means
it backfired badly and there are other
stocks that work quite well and
surprisingly done
everything works well
they still run they run
wonderfully they keep their level and
others give a [ __ ] and I think
you also have to have a healthy mix
I didn't subscribe to Porsche I
would buy them at some point
when they get the first dent that's
guaranteed to happen and then I
'll put a few more Porsche shares in the
portfolio because I also have a
portfolio I have to  To be honest,
where I don't look every day
means I bought it, I bought it too
There are shares that are 10 years old, but there are
shares that are sometimes even 15
years old, they are still in the depot
because I don’t need to touch the poles and
the depot I earn
enough new fresh money at the end of the day,
which is always there  it
's basically the
old-age provision that's there and it's
all getting long and we know that, a
stock merchant and then takes a
sleeping pill and looks back in 10
years and then it's all
okay if you have the best company, of course
best company i have made a
lot of money over the last 28 or
30 years with sap sap is a
share that has always
gone up you have a lot of money
i made money with apple i made money with google
made money with amazon so i saw it all
myself  Classic, I haven't
seen it myself, but of course you
had these companies in
your portfolio and if you haven't been
looking for a long time, there  if that comes with the
sleeping pill then you are of course
completely self-sufficient and then you are completely self-
sufficient so we actually cost money that
cost me money yes that
also cost me money oh what he was there yes there
too you weren’t there
but God  thanks a few
hundred thousand everyone were
n't gone again but how come a guy who
's already in a very special
mood what's her name then Beach and then
it says I just was just
bought for how much yes I just bought
for 10 million that works  through
the ceiling there runs runs then you catch
it and then you say everything clearly
I think I had the same
experience I come out of a club
come out of the club in San
tropez at the Beach Club and there come in
two German guys  and saying, for
God's sake, you can't buy a Tesla
, it's hops, everything sucks, it's been
4 years, I never
bought a Tesla, so I took all the profits with
me  because I listened to the
guys I just hear it in my ear
it goes Friday it goes wrong it does
n't work and the tesla has tripled for
four for ten times so I was
n't there that means I'm also
one of those guys from the  Belly buys
the one who doesn’t care much about
this is I’m such a gut
decides a principle of yours to be
success principle maybe also so gut
decision to make super brave
so buying castles like
that founding hotels are big
investments and they  must first
trust has earned a lot of money
that doesn't mean that you
then have the courage to
just lie down investments tell me I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm taking the full risk I've figured that
out now yes that's probably this
gut feeling and sometimes you're
lucky  sometimes you're unlucky, of course you have to
see that you're
more lucky than unlucky
overall, otherwise you'll realize at some point flycatcher
lies that is  t I believe what I
learned then in this
whole trading history, also about
all these fair people, that you always start
again the next season
you have to have courage again, you have
to invest new money to
be successful and what’s
the point of that  biggest investment ever Islam
so where did you make
the most money in one
go so I
guaranteed made the most money back then in the property here
in Monaco that was the most expensive thing that cost the
most money and that
please bought that’s a complex yes this one
The apartment complex was of
course already relatively expensive in Monaco back then
, you would have had to keep it until today,
then if you bought it at the
billion on the way, unfortunately
10,000 10,000 marks I think
that was the square meter we
are in Monaco today at 100,000 euros then
can you calculate the whole
thing if you bought something for 100 million
wi  Are you today at 1.5 at almost two
billion for a property of the
size of 25 26 apartments in
Monaco that of course everything went up like a
rocket that of
course you couldn't know and so there
are certain things that you  she
never forgot I'm sitting at the
Italian's, a
well-known Dutchman calls me, our Robert, I
've got something completely new and he
also does some tech etc and then he says to
me, yes, let's meet at the
Italian's, I'll imagine that  I
bring my laptop with me then it
arrives and that's the problem I have here
what have you ever heard of
krypton
I know looked and stars or
something wrong and then he says yes there
is such a strange new currency
that is coming out  it will replace everything else it
's called bitcoins
today we all know what that is back then
no one knew what that was that was five
six years ago or what
it was the price of bitcoin was
at  026
Cent, he was already a big part of
this bitcoin story and
tried to put it in my eye
then I sit at lunch and
he chewed my ear off for two hours
it almost bled then I
said come on it's hanging  good is good i
buy 50,000 of that dick stop
now i go home i go
to the computer now and how can i buy
then he explained that to me then i go
home and then try to buy that [ __ ]
from 4 hours in front of the computer
sat and didn't
get it sorted so I had him come the
next day that his cell phone
didn't work then you can come to
me you have to help now you have to do it
now and then it
didn't work for him either that was it  At that time
I couldn't go on saying that God I'll
buy Bitcoin and sell it and
that was a complicated thing
to get something like that in your wool or on
your stick e  r didn't get his act together that
day either,
today I'm annoyed, of course,
calculating if you had bought those [ __ ] bitcoins for 50,000 only
for 50,000 at 0 26
you would
have been with me again today, that means I
want twice the chance of that to
Being twice worked out
so now I have to go on living as a millionaire
but that was your portfolio
you just talked
about television a bit
real estate is very important but now hotel
so what's that all about hotel
is basically there  I arrived
in the in the second crisis, not
in 2000, but then went the whole year
into the 2008 case when the whole
financial crisis came, I
had just bought a
large plot of land
near Sonthofen and
built three wills  Of course, before 2008 everyone
wanted a villa and that was chic
and then I said okay then
we need it  there were three wills with
three pools and and on 10,000
square meters of land and
then offered them, then came the financial crisis
and then came, of course, in
France and also the new
government, which then started
with special taxes and assets and God
knows  what all and
then these wills were not for sale,
so definitely not for the prices
I had imagined and then
I just let them stand for two
years but unfortunately the financial crisis
lasted a little longer
than these two years felt
at all  Case for the real estate and
then we decided without further ado
I came and what are we going to do out there
Boutique hotel that is what is
actually happening at the moment and where is everywhere in San
tropez suddenly there are
smaller hotels that have 12 14 16 20
rooms we have 16 so  we said
all right, the living room, the dining room, they
will simply be converted from the
kitchen  is there in the bathroom then
we have three customs then otherwise we
still have five rooms so we now have 18
rooms in our Prestige season in
Grimm oh and it’s going wonderfully we
have eight employees the people are
happy they have really cool
rooms the gardens  on 10,000
square meters is super laid out because it
was just luxury villas that we are now
into the hotel and there you can German
guests who are Dirk or that are of
course at the beginning there is television
again and of course many
German guests came who saw it on
television  they said
all right we want to go to the
Geissens, we've
already seen the rooms on TV etc and
meanwhile we have
international clientele in the
in the what costs you there different
so the ones who start the cheapest
I think  in the low season
we are I think about 180 to 200 €
for the room it will of course be
de  correspondingly more 6 7 800 € and
uh, we only hear positive feedback
from it so and with that you are
not so busy every day
people two managers plus plus 6
employees who manage the whole thing for
us and
at the end of the day money comes out that
's exactly  everything that goes into the
bowl from the right and from the left
and from this bowl the rest is
paid
for, for example,
or the cars how many cars do you have
best number but my wife also
said either sell at one or
buy no so I'm going  assuming we're
still buying in but 13 these are
all cars now, each of which will probably
cost at least 100,000 euros somehow, yes, unfortunately, no, there are
two more that look a little cheaper,
we still have a Mini Cooper and we
still have a small Toyota
but these are now more or
less our hotel cars that are parked for the
staff, the others
you simply collect or sell  Yes, I
'm such a little mess when it comes to cars,
I can't separate what I
collect and then
finally put their trusty ones everywhere and and and because
I think at some point these
cars won't exist anymore and then it's glad
when you do  also has a burner
, even if you have to buy the later one in the
pharmacy, that's just the
way it is, but I think then you have
the pans again from the noise and from
what so I'm not a car dealer, otherwise
I would also sell then I would have
yes less
so I buy and keep actually
always
okay so when you listen to them that
somehow it all sounds so mega
simple so there is also something where
you have to torture yourself now that maybe it
didn’t work out that way or you say okay
so now you understand investments
but somehow it's so super easy
you can you have to if if you go back
to the origin the
Uncle Sam box wasn't super easy but it was
fine  en the basis of
being able to live without worries and then having accumulated heaps of coal
from which to
draw and then it is of course relatively
easy to buy real estate, to
restore it, to renovate it
and to resell it, you
just need a feel for which one  Location
you do that and since with real estate
location location location is the number one
you just have to be where
people want to go and we're
lucky that we're here on the Cote d'
Azur people want or wanted to go to Monaco
definitely still Monaco they
wanted to can they wanted the
entropy that's the real estate in the
last 20 25 years the
real estate here has tripled the
deputies for five to six
sometimes for tenfold so in that
respect you couldn't really do anything
wrong if you  invested your money there
if we come back to the stocks now
how I sold my company
95 was the stock index d  he
Germans over 1800 points where are we
today we are at 14,000 today
so no matter which shares you bought
on VW or Daimler etc.
20 years ago you would have ten times the
money today but I am currently so a
bit that you have the feeling it will be
now a little less because it
was like that here in Monaco last year
first feeling it's decreasing a
bit now maybe not
so much Russian money e.g. isn't
here anymore but do you actually feel
declining effects you have the
feeling it's going here  further the boy so
here the bow just stops that
you notice because the real estate is still
all sold out everything is for rent
you notice that this this little place
you mustn't forget Monaco has
36000 inhabitants that's small that's
yes  like a like a
small town in Germany and you can
tell that more and more people are coming from the
north from Scandinavia from Finland from
Sweden  en from England etc come to
Monaco to here simply security security
are a very big keyword
save taxes you can go anywhere in the world you
can go over it you can go to the
Isle of Man you can go to
Portugal meanwhile there is a
flat rate in Italy buying
real estate in Italy  if you pay 100,000 € more
taxes yesterday to
Portugal up to 12 years tax-free
you go as a European to London which
also doesn't pay taxes that
means there are a lot of places in
this world where you don't pay taxes
there's only Monaco  one of but of
course you have the second advantage here you
have an insane security Monaco
is a small police state on every
corner there is a policeman or one in
civilian clothes the whole of Monaco is under video surveillance
if your wallet is stolen here
you can now watch it on television
like that  that means that
comes on top of that and if you have children
you have the schools they are here  r
just as perfect as they very
likely are in Munich or
Hamburg but they are perfect like that and you
can just let your children run freely across
the street here you do
n’t have to be afraid on a tour they
will be mugged they will be kidnapped
they will be raped or  God
knows what Monaco is very, very safe
and of course the safety also gives
rich people a
certain value, so it's not
just that you pay less tax
here because the fact is, for
everything I do in Germany, I still have to in
Germany  Paying
taxes means Monaco
doesn't do me any good at first my private situation
is covered in Monaco but everything
I earn in the hotel
in France I have to pay tax in France
everything I earn with my production company
in Germany I have to pay
tax in Germany so that means  here
I'm just
exempt from income tax and
inheritance tax  moderately exempt for
that I need income but first
I have no income or no taxes
to pay
I mean a lot of the things you
do are aimed at the
audience let’s say it’s more like
a broad mass and the
mass is logically  is not that
wealthy and doesn’t have the same
opportunities it’s still your
taste, I mean the things
you’re wearing now yourself, a
t-shirt from my collection I’m seeing
here right now and jewelery from his
collection but that’s
really the case  your that
you think that's cool too, although it's actually
aimed at people who
aren't or can't be your personal bubble
, yes, but that's my
style, you know, that's what I design
too, that's what I do  I did that back then
with Uncle Sam,
I do that today with Roberto Geissini, I
love the clothes I make,
so I ask them, I wear them
actually every day that means I
don't need to go to a boutique that
your new jeans and you
wear them torn meanwhile that means wearing them for a long time so we always need
sustainable for that you
always need the new t-shirt and new t-
shirt  Shirts come out at Roberto
geissini every month, which means I have
new clothes in my closet every month,
but that means you
have contact with a target group,
so although you live a completely different life
than your customers, in the end
your viewers do too  People
who buy products,
life is different from you, logically, I
think we have the
advantage, of course, the Cote d'Azur and
Monaco speak for themselves, too, we
don't feel really rich because there
are people walking around down there  your shoes fall
out when you go into the harbor
down there, there are boats of 120m, there
goes a dillbar, a thing like that
costs 500 million d  that means down
there there you just
feel normal and we feel normal too and
I think that's also the
success we've had and why all
television works for so long
because we're very, very authentic we
're not aloof  even if we are now
going for a walk in a yacht and I
don't get out of the Rolls-Royce
and my nose is all the way up I
just get out there with my Roberto
Geissini T-shirt and fill up my car myself
meanwhile you've learned how to
do that too  arrived in the whole social media
world meanwhile you do
now than i you have but instagram
i think you lost half a million
so you post than not that often
but there is already a story live
so it is now also a new
universe where you  you also do a lot yes we
have of course arrived everywhere
definitely the Chamber started with it
I then said at some point in the mood
all right I need now also  h an
Instagram from the Viennese helped me
to open it
worked wonderfully meanwhile as
you say 500,000 or something like that
I post but sometimes a
bit of crap that happens
because you post something quickly my
children are much more
professional on the road  came the same
way but you have to face the media
you have to do with it that the new era
and I don’t want to close my mind there either
that means we will
try everything we will
smell everything that is like the Geissens podcast that
there is exactly
we sniffed it too, we
looked at it, we did it, we
recorded six episodes, it was
very successful, that means I
think we were all the
best format broadcast by celebrities with the
marketers that we have there, that
means it is  well done the children
have to decide at some point
do they want to use it  Doing iter should be
a future or was it just
a trip in a direction
that might cost us too much time
that we might not like etc.
or do we continue and that's
just that we get a taste of everything,
you see  on real estate hotel
textiles television podcast I know
if tomorrow it will be an ice cream parlor it will be
an ice cream parlor tomorrow, then we will sniff it
or lick it and
then decide afterwards whether we
like it, whether we enjoy it, whether he will
follow it, whether we will continue with it
want that is lucrative is fun is
profitable is and then we'll
continue it wait a few words about
your marketing service also relatively
large testimonial so from Müller Milch
and CHECK24 so or Verivox what
I think so the most diverse
partnerships over the years you've
already made  yes we did a
lot we did Holidaycheck back
then we did Sonnenklar TV
about üb  he several years my children
are active there Carmen are active we of
course also do a lot for hotels
etc we have done a lot for
resource in the Maldives and are of
course constantly looking for
new challenges for new
stories that you can advertise
that you can  you can add
to our system and that was a journey
and finances through yes journey finances that
is actually our main topic and
it is you so would like to
say somehow okay I think we
are of course very, very open to
business, especially for the children  because
the children speak to a completely
different target group, of course, to all the
young people who are now growing up, etc.
me and of course the clientele who
get carried away by it, we have a
lot of people who experience it again and again
, but came to Instagram that people
write on it no matter you were  the
Maldives we flew there super
great yes because everyone was so everyone has
M  close people who followed these trips that we
made on this world trip that
we made who
said before we saw that
with you you were on the
sam-bubble Islands we didn't even know
that there were the loungers 60 60 miles
In front of Panama are the Maldives, there are
320 islands that look like the
Maldives, hardly anyone knows that, of course, we
discovered them through our trip, they brought them
close to a viewer and some people
had these sailing ships, they
borrowed money or catamarans
visited this island  and that's something
we've been doing more and more
when you're listening here and
bigger or a successful company
and says okay, I find it exciting
I'd like to do something with the Geissens or with
one of the children or with Robert
, just see what's there
we are of course always interested in cooperation
, we can
introduce him to any direction
any kind of cooperation for a
one-off payment on
on on on as I said on
there you just have to look at it you
just have to discuss it as it comes
, depending on who has
what we are open so if you are
interested you can
write to me somehow then do
it  go on and we'll bring the big
thing back to the setbacks
, so there weren't really such big setbacks,
so
apart from now a few stock market
investments are of course
always better, don't forget
the one or two setbacks for the first time on the stock market
I also had
some real estate
permits to work with. I
paid attention to the permits for months,
not to say sometimes years, until
you get certain things through with the authorities.
Everyone
who has done real estate knows that
You have friends too and I have  e of
course I also lost a lot of money
because I listened to other people
or listened to friends, a
recent story, one of
my friends told me he really
stole money from me, that means yes
, it was about the lion’s den is going
very well  very good so what do you do you
do something similar to the
lion's den but not necessarily on television
but you just set
up a company to support start-ups
and I found that a very interesting new
number and then I listened to the whole
thing  and so different
companies were really
familiar with it and then it was said Robert that
's mega that's awesome we'll open up
then we'll support
start-ups and and and we just have to
collect funds now that means how
do we do it  because yes we
are all paying in money now we are doing
awesome share capital etc okay what do I have to do
yes you have to pay in cola yes okay so
if you say so  st then we'll
do it, but you're the guarantor
that everything works, you're the
managing director, you organize, yes,
Robert, nothing can go wrong, I
've got my hands on it, I'll take care of
it, okay,
hundreds of thousands of euros invested in
all these channels at lightning speed  in and what
happened the money was deducted
at the end of the day you look at
the accounts today on the customer is more than
0 performance zero collected zero the
only one who paid in who was that you
that stupid Robert crass so
meanwhile you have to admit that of course  The whole
thing is now pending with the attorney's office, which means I'm going to the end of
it. You know that from my wife, too, when she
has problems with some
people who hit on my children, whether they
're rappers or whoever
they are, they come through and  I'm going
through this story as well, I wo
n't let any friends take
money out of my pocket  for
any business that then enriches itself at the
end of the day, so
you never made the startup
bigger because of that, of course, I didn’t make
startup investments, so that was
the idea in the end, it was good, as
I said, that would have been before where there were of
course different ones
There are Family Offices where of course I know some people who are
always interested
in investing,
similar to the lion's den, just
not in the first go public but
basically investing in companies that need money
that have a good idea
that you  can support that you can help
that was the basic idea and that's
why i said all right then
i'll invest
money with you like that and as i said if you can
only be deducted by family
friends or people you
trust they can deduct you otherwise  it's
your own fault if you
invest somewhere in the stock market and the stocks
fall  yes then they drop yes but
otherwise pull off either
your own wife pulls off the family or
your boyfriend okay that means there are
sometimes difficult moments for you
difficult moments of course that doesn’t make me
completely poor but it’s
annoying you know you’re one  is
offended yourself you know you
lose faith in
people and you become isolated as a
result you don't trust the people
around you you know they're
people you go on vacation with
who you spend your free time
with  you go out to eat etc. or then you
're sure I'll invest money there in a
similar way to giving my best
friend €1,000 and saying someone
gives it up front and he doesn't give it away and
goes running with the €1,000 so sorry
that's it
unimaginable and and also had the offer to take part
in the lion cave, I
mean that would actually
have been perfect no no no so we have
we have TV-wise  With 50
episodes that we produce a year,
we have so much to do that we
can't actually afford other large formats
, that means Carmen
once did this Let's Dance at a time when there was a bit of leeway
and then did  I
found out for myself that three months or 4
months of dancing, of course, everything else is
left in the time we could
n't produce anything for the Geissens
and then had
to produce the whole summer after Let's Dance
, so that means what they
take away from you in terms of free time  who is
somewhere else and that's why we
're so busy on television with 200
days of shooting we still need a
bit of free time for ourselves
free time Monaco means
traveling with many other Germans
there's the famous story from the
podcast and Alex there's a
regulars' table one  whatsapp group where you
then and Kevin Volland who
plays football here and nikolücke was
gl  I have the Formula 1 drivers all
here together from time to time in the
group you vote where you go and eat out in the
evening or something like
that, social life takes place here under the
German city, no, so we
founded German regulars’ tables, we
stand out  Boys actually at the moment
the women come along from
time to time and there is, as you rightly
said, it will be there that
Kevin Volland will be there that Nico
Hülkenberg will be me and of course
half a dozen other people and
we will meet  then on a day like
today bright sunshine somewhere
on the beach or in a restaurant or
you get WhatsApp tonight
the café tomorrow there the day after tomorrow you
can say yes or you
just don't say anything so a very
casual number we already have an
episode  so of course not a whole episode made out of it,
but of course we
invited all the boys
up here to the barbecue and had  n here the
Geissens all watched together on Monday evenings
and had a lot of fun so there
are also legendary parties you do so
I've been told that from time
to time somehow uh you really get on your
[ __ ] there who's hitting clear we've got it
right often enough
kicked ass in SAN tropez, we've also had big
parties, mainly of
course the children's birthday parties,
which of course also appear in the show,
we just
celebrated a huge Oktoberfest a week
before the meadows in Munich, we have a
huge Oktoberfest in San tropez
held but let yourself be surprised
that comes with the goats how many
people were there 200 200 all
friends acquaintances yes friends acquaintances yes
actually friends unknown people in your
villa very probably more well-known
than friends because we know with
friends that can sometimes go wrong
but rather more well-known okay but
still there is something like that with you too  s like
real friendships there are
logically real friendships
yes yes if you look at your marriage yes
it is predestined somehow something like
that this is the greatest friendship
we have no that means we have
been together for 40 years
yes and it works works stops the
wife is happy  I'm satisfied
find yes we are still tinkering with it the
children have to attach attach and
then decide we
know
that still at the best age so
what do you do what else
to expect from you so further consequences yes
plans for the future is of course very clear
we  we will continue to work on the
Geissens we still have good
ideas we will set ourselves up
in Dubai we will get one or the other
business off the ground in Dubai in the
next few months that is
the first objective we have now
because we are such a  see that
Europe is not the rocket at the moment
, I think that Europe is a bis at the moment
is stagnating and not to say
that Europe
is going into reverse gear a bit with all the
problems we have here and
that's why we decided to
look for something in winter and there were just two
options either you go to the
mountains or you go skiing  or you
go to the front so the sun
we have here too but logically
in December January February March it also leaves something
to be desired here then
you have 14 15 16 degrees in Dubai are
30 and we have always had a soft spot
for Dubai  and we will line up in
Dubai for the winter months,
we will create one business in Dubai,
we will also
do real estate there because the
real estate in Dubai is of
course working mega moderately at the moment
, you
can see that in the development when  if it does
n't work in Europe, it
works abroad, you can see that more and
more in our entire
circle of acquaintances  people all
want to have a foot abroad
and going abroad means
having a foot in the door outside of Europe and
Dubai is of course predestined you know
modern you know currently you know
just very luxurious in terms of life
there is security  is of course
also the very best and in this respect
I believe that things will really get going for the next 15
to 20 years and
I don't want to say that this will definitely happen in Saudi
Arabia in the
next five years because they
also have some projects
You just have to wait and see before you want to realize that, but I think
Dubai was the pioneer for all the
girls
who managed to get something done that
works where everyone wants to go, regardless of whether they
want to go on holiday or live there
we don't want to
start from home now we just want to use the
winter months for it and want
to line up there, that means
projects  do and do real estate projects like that
yes yes we
have already done one or the other real estate
project new projects that we
are tackling and will now
set up in Dubai and we are bigger than um how
we did it before
again 10 20 million and something like that yes in
the direction  so we will
definitely buy several apartments in Dubai
we will accompany one or the other
construction project down there
we plan to do cosias service etc
with another partner company
down there Shania really wants to have the
studio we have
already put out the feelers down there  after something like
2300 square meters of art studio where we of
course also
want to take in other artists who can
realize themselves there because not everyone
has the money to afford their own gallery or
their own studio in Dubai,
so you can jerk off one or the other
artist from time to time
Paints pictures and basically wants a
kind of art base  Monkeys for one of our
daughters the other would like to
make this real estate history as I said Real
estate in Dubai is
absolutely bumarkt at the moment so the prices have risen
because the interest rates in Dubai
have certainly not gone down at the moment
but have also
gone up  I think at the moment
the cash is laughing and everyone who has it in
the account can be happy that it
is there and I think that the banks
are getting more expensive as always, so in that
respect I think you have to be very, very
flexible and
Monaco Dubai is Dubai  a transshipment
place where you can actually
shoot real estate relatively quickly because it's
very, very international,
people don't just come from Europe, they
come from Asia, they come from everywhere,
Bangladesh, Iran, Iraq, etc.
there are smaller problems everywhere and in Dubai
that's just fine  world for
people like that and not just for the Europeans and
I think it's for the next 10 15
20  Years of a real market that shouldn’t
be underestimated are you following something like that
or you sound very
skeptical about Europe um that means you’re also
already being politically interested
so energy costs will logically rise
by then and you’ve got your
thoughts on Europe isn’t pure
in a gut feeling apparently yes I'm not close at all
I'm not
necessarily the one who is
very interested in politics but of
course you get what you hear from the
news you can see that we
have energy problems in Europe these
energy problems naturally exist in the
Middle East in  the shape doesn't
stretch straws the earth and
oil comes out that means we have to
buy somewhere because we don't have it
in this respect they of course have
the first advantage the second
advantage is that it never gets cold in Dubai
that means a heater  if you
both you don't need it so we
don't have heating costs for that we have a
lot  Slight
air conditioning must see that was a
water coming but I'll just say
I see a new world there, although I
think that would be
living in the old world in Europe at the moment and in America the
same will be the consideration whether he still
go to Miami whether we  set us up there
but America is also old world if
you just look at the wiring of the houses
if you look at the bridges in
America etc everything is old in
Dubai everything is new
in the Middle East everything is new if the
Saudis start building their cities there
now  neon what they want to build there
should become a futures city etc. then
you know what will happen there in the next 20 years
and if you just
reflect on the past
100 years ago we hardly drove a
car 30 years ago nobody had a mobile phone 40 years ago
For years nobody knew how a
computer works and now think about
the development how it should
look like in 30 years
in 30 years it will probably run  ch
no longer fly across the street,
everything is just flying around the world with drones
and Dubai will definitely be
one of the pioneers there, or the center is one of the
pioneers because we have an old
infrastructure, they are currently building a
new one
and have a foothold in it  I think
for six months we're not even talking about
wanting to leave here
I still think Monaco is good I still
think San trope is good I
think Ibiza is good etc I think the entire
Mediterranean Sea is great for the months of May to
October and  after that you have
to come up with something and I
think my means are quite well
positioned there
okay okay um well I took a
lot with me but yes I had a lot of
fun so you contradicted that openly and
honestly and lived it
yourself so congratulations on the
You have to say that you
really have a knack for the
beautiful life and that you make me
very
successful only work b  nothing wrestles
what wishes daughters what for my
daughters if of course I wish them
all the best that they find good partners
that they master their path in life
that at the end of the day they also know
which professional
direction they really want to take as
I said we will do it for everyone  help
win support be there and
they simply have to decide for themselves
what they want to do but they have
other origins, so to speak, logically completely different
than you had and they
ask if you want the same have the same
ambition and yes, we
tried to teach them that of course  and
I think they're very very
down to earth and like I said they
've got their own caliber now they've got
their own direction they're making their
own money they're self-reliant now
need to build on that see
they get the hang of it or
else you'll have to wait until  Papa and
Mama no longer see and then you can
get the money from Papa Mama  spend
what's left but that's
over thanks please ciao ciao this
podcast is produced by Pots
at OMR